you know what I'm saying I've been to
like the year that you made the freshman
cover was that 2010 2010 yeah so the
2010 freshman cover and in 2000 20 you
get nominated for best rap album 2021 is
when the Grammys were right yeah it's
like 11 years later right my freshman
year freshman cover it's probably only
like three guys left on that that you
want to hear because it's you with
nipples on that cover me nope yeah
pill Pew shout out to Pale Man you know
I've kind of discovered both of you all
together low-key where's
who else is under the cover um J Cole
Cole was on that guy God damn that's a
crazy cover very cool oh oh the juice
man six rings on like a basketball
player six rings on like a bet that was
his freestyle you know how I remember it
because you were were you a part of that
because there was only two lines of it
six rings on like a basketball playing
what six rings on like a basketball
player I was like what the [ __ ] am I up
here what are we doing yes I'm up here
rapping my ass off
six reasons like a basketball player hey
y'all like oh my God I was like oh I was
like [ __ ] I said what am I that's it I
said I don't know if I'm gonna be in
this rap game long man like I said it's
you know what I'm saying and I love I
love old lady juice man you know Classic
record shout out to OJ that was a
classic freshman freestyle that he did
right there too that was amazing
memorable you remember you never
remember I don't remember my [ __ ] my
[ __ ] was been weak I remember his though
for sure stood out
that let me know right there like it
stood out and sometimes you got to do
things that stand out more than others
and that that's what that that's what
that day taught me I didn't condemn his
freestyle I was just like huh you know I
mean like what am I doing but it was God
teaching me a lesson like look [ __ ]
this like you yeah you think you can rap
you got a lot of words you put together
but that [ __ ] right there had
Showmanship and you don't have that yet
that's that's fair yeah I mean we had a
freestyle go viral this dude named Haiti
baby I don't know if you saw it he was
like uh
he was like hi hi it was crazy it went
viral Rihanna posted it everybody posted
it and it was when I walked like when I
was sitting next to the guy I was like
this is like the worst [ __ ] I've ever is
that that [ __ ] that you was with uh
what me and head you went head yeah
shout out DJ here man good guy man
salute to my brother DJ hand